la gravité des cas de contamination
était infiniment plus faible quand on a
justement dit aux gens de rester chez
eux et c'est à partir du moment où ils
ce sont des confits n'est que là il
revient d'avoir cette explosion mais non
c'était bien de voir clairement et pour
moi je peux pas laisser dire ça parce
que c'est particulièrement injuste pour
les boîtes de nuit moi je vous soutiens
amis pour cent je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
parce que moi je suis dans le sud cet
été je suis allé à saint tropez chez à
la can toutes les boîtes étaient fermés
c'était c'est injuste pourquoi parce que
tu coûtes tous les restaurants se sont
transformés en boîte de nuit j y étais
donc je peux en témoigner je le
reconnais je l'assumé je lave où j étais
de bois deux étaient des boîtes de nuit
mais ambulances étaient en baisse était
incontestable et là j'ai discuté avec un
patron de boîte de nuit qui était au
bord de l'agonie financière c'était un
drame parce qu'ils rentrent en
dépression au bord du suicide
donc c'est aussi grave excuse moi que la
maladie d'accord parce qu'il ya des gens
qui se suicident aujourd'hui de la perte
de leur entreprise et l'américain santé
mentale et c'est tant mieux s'il vous
plaît monsieur excuse moi et qui voit en
face dans la rue un restaurant tu fait
leur travail avec des gentils dans ce
poème pelops je les fais sans masques
sont rien personne ne leur dit rien
pourquoi cette injustice et je peins
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui les boîtes se
révoltent parce que quand ils ont
réouvert cet été après le confinement
ils ont laissé les restaurants faire dé
devenir des boîtes de nuit mais par
contre toi de ces boîtes de nuit n'ont
pas tu crèves et puis toi tu vis
normalement juste un truc concret à
monsieur parce que on a parlé quand même
jeunes est de 15000 euros qui pourrait
être prolongé jusqu'à fin décembre je
sais que vous êtes vous attendez un
décret pour que cette aide soit plus
accessible à la loyale n'y étant pas le
voyais à camille mais il ya également
quand même d'aider
des gérants de boîtes de nuit qui
demandent actuellement carrément à
l'état de clairement rembourser leur
fond de commerce est ce que c'est une
démarche que vous envisagez alors oui
effectivement il ya plusieurs de mes
collègues qui demande que l'état en fait
nous rachète nos fonds de commerce mais
il trouve l'argent ou à un moment l'état
l'a réellement c'est de la folie mais
pour quelqu'un qui est propriétaire du
fond et des murs à la rigueur je peux
peut-être encore l'entendre mois exemple
moins cher à l'achat qu'un propriétaire
de mes murs ça veut dire que l'état me
rachèterait mon fond et en plus
signerait un bail avec mon propriétaire
ça me semble un peu compliqué à tenir